WE ARE IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
ANOTHER PROMINENT LIBERAL
CAUGHT IN A RACIST PHOTO
SCANDAL.
CANADIAN PRIME MINISTER
JUSTIN TRUDEAU FACING A
FIRESTORM OVER WEARING A
BLACK FACE IN A 2001 PHOTO.
IT HAPPENED DURING AN
ARABIAN KNIGHT THEMED PARTY
AT A SCHOOL WHERE HE WAS A
29-YEAR-OLD TEACHER.
TRUDEAU APOLOGIZING LAST
NIGHT BUT THEN TWO MORE
EXAMPLES EMERGED.
ONE FROM HOSPITAL IN THE
1990S WHERE HE IS WEARING A
WIG PERFORMING A JAMAICAN
FOLK SONG AT A TALENT SHOW.
THE OTHER A VIDEO SHOWING
HIM IN BLACK FACE WAVING HIS
HANDS AROUND AND STICKING
HIS TONGUE OUT.
TRUDY
TRUDEAU FORCE TO APOLOGY
GUIDE AGAIN THIS AFTERNOON.
HE HIT ALL THE LIBERAL BUZZ
WORDS INTERSECTIONALITY AND
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS AND HE
DIDN'T RULE OUT THAT THERE
COULD BE MORE PHOTOS.
>> I APPRECIATE CALLING IT
MAKEUP BUT IT WAS BLACK
FACE.
AND THAT IS JUST NOT RIGHT.
I DIDN'T SEE THAT FROM THE
LAYERS OF PRIVILEGE THAT I
HAVE.
I AM WEARY OF BEING
DEFINITIVE ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE THE RECENT PICTURES
THAT CAME OUT I HAD NOT
REMEMBERED.
>> Jesse: THIS SCANDAL IS
EXPOSING TRUDEAU'S OFF THE
CHARTS HYPOCRISY.
HE HAS FASHIONED HIMSELF AS
THE PRIME MINISTER OF WOKE
AND A LIBERAL FOR COUNTER
WEIGHT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WATCH.
>> I WILL KEEP SAYING I'M A
FEMINIST UNTIL AS YOU SAY
IT'S MET WITH YEAH, WE KNOW
THAT MOVE ON.
WE SHOULDN'T BE TALKING
ABOUT TOLERANCE.
WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT
LOVE AND ACCEPTANCE AND
FRIENDSHIP AND RESPECT.
>> WE SHOULDN'T BE AFRAID OF
THE WORD FEMINIST.
MEN AND WOMEN SHOULD USE IT
TO DESCRIBE THEMSELVES ANY
TIME THEY WANT.
>> THE FUTURE OF MANKIND.
SO WE WOULD LIKE.
>> WE LIKE TO SEE PEOPLE
KIND NOT NECESSARILY
MANKIND.
IT'S MORE INCLUSIVE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: OKAY.
JEDEDIAH, WENT FROM WOKE TO
A JOKE IN ABOUT ONE NIGHT
AND DO YOU THINK HE CAN
SURVIVE?
>> Jedediah: THIS GUY IS
LAYERS DEEP OF INSUFFERABLE.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, SOME
POLITICIANS ARE
INSUFFERABLE.
THIS GUY HAS LAYERS OF IT.
IT'S CRAZY TO ME THIS THIRD
INSTANCE, HE WAS 29 YEARS
OLD.
HE WAS A TEACHER.
THAT'S A GROWN MAN.
THAT'S NOT A STUDENT IN HIGH
SCHOOL THAT CAN YOU SAY OH,
YOU KNOW, I WAS AN IDIOT
KID.
YOU ARE 29 YEARS OLD.
YOU ARE GROWN.
AND YOU STILL DON'T KNOW.
MY FAVORITE PART OF THIS IS
THE QUOTE HE GIVES WHEN HE
SAYS I DIDN'T CONSIDER IT
RACIST AT THE TIME BUT NOW
WE KNOW BETTER.
THAT WAS IN 2001.
IN -- THIS WAS NOT A PHOTO
THAT SOMEBODY TOOK IN 1960
OF SOMEONE WHERE YOU COULD
SAY, YOU KNOW, THE TIMES ARE
DIFFERENT.
PEOPLE DIDN'T REALIZE THE
SEVERITY OF WHAT THEY WERE
DOING.
THEY DIDN'T REALIZE HOW
OFFENSIVE IT WAS.
IN 2001.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US AT
THIS TABLE WAS AN ADULT IN
2001 WHO KNEW WELL AND GOOD
ENOUGH THAT YOU DON'T PUT
BLACK FACE ON AND BEHAVE
THIS WAY AS A GROWN ADULT
TEACHING ALSO YOU ARE A
TEACHER WHAT KIND OF EXAMPLE
ARE YOU SETTING?
THIS GUY WITH ALL HIS P.C.
NONSENSE AND ALWAYS TRYING
TO SEEM SO WONDERFUL AND OH,
I SUGAR COAT ALL MY WORDS
NOT TO OFFEND ANYONE.
HE IS BRACING US FOR MORE
STUFF THAT'S COMING.
HE WOULDN'T HAVE SAID THERE
COULD BE MORE PHOTOS.
I GUARANTEE THERE IS GOING
TO SEE SOMETHING EVEN WORSE
THAN THIS COMING DOWN THE
PIKE.
>> Jesse: SHOULD HE RESIGN,
JUAN?
>> Juan: NO.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE AS A BLACK
PERSON I SHOULD STAY OUT OF
THIS CONVERSATION.
I'M INTERESTED TO LEARN.
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT
JEDEDIAH SAID IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
I THINK THAT IF YOU ARE 29
YEARS OLD, YOU SHOULD KNOW
ABOUT THE HISTORY OF THINGS
LIKE BIRTH OF A NATION AND
MINSTREL SHOWS AND, YOU
KNOW, DEPICTING THE OTHER
MINORITIES AND IT COULD BE
ORIENTALISM AS IT'S CALLED
OR DEPICTING IRISH PEOPLE AS
DRUNKS.
YOU COULD GO ON WITH ALL THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE IN AMERICA
KNOW TOO WELL.
BUT THE WHOLE IDEA IS THAT
THE OTHER IS LAZY, DUMB, YOU
KNOW, NOT A GOOD WORKER.
NOT TO BE TRUSTED.
AND IT'S ALL A BASIS FOR
RACIST BEHAVIOR FOR
EXCLUDING PEOPLE.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE PROBLEM
HERE IS I FIND IT SO
INTERESTING, AS, YOU KNOW
FROM, A POLITICAL ANALYST
POINT OF VIEW, HE IS BEING
ATTACKED IN CANADA AS NOT AS
ADVERTISED.
THAT IS THE SLOGAN BEING
USED BY CONSERVATIVES IN
CANADA TO ATTACK TRUDEAU
DURING A VERY CLOSE RACE.
I THINK THE ELECTION IS
OCTOBER 21st.
AND HE HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
MOVE AHEAD OF HIS
CONSERVATIVE CHALLENGER.
AND NOW THE QUESTION IS WHAT
ABOUT THE LIBERALS IN
CANADA?
SO YOU DEPICT HIM AS A
HYPOCRITE.
BUT THE LIBERALS IN CANADA
NOW START TO AGREE WITH THE
CONSERVATIVES IN CANADA THAT
WELL, MAYBE THIS GUY
SHOULDN'T BE THE SWORD
CARRIER FOR LIBERAL
IDEOLOGY.
HE PREVIOUSLY HAS MADE HIS
CABINET, A CABINET THAT HE
SAYS LOOKS LIKE CANADA.
IT'S DIVERSE.
IT'S ONE HALF WOMEN.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
>> Jesse: IS HE FOR REAL?
>> Jesse: YOU DON'T THINK HE
SHOULD RESIGN.
WHAT ABOUT IF REPUBLICAN
POLITICIAN IN 2001 HAD A
BLACK FACE LIKE THAT.
DO YOU STILL THINK THEY
SHOULD HANG ON AND FIGHT IT
THE WAY TRUDEAU IS?
>> Juan: NO, THAT'S A
DIFFERENTIAL DYNAMIC, JESSE.
>> Jesse: DIFFERENT DYNAMIC
WHEN IT'S A DIFFERENT
POLITICAL PARTY.
>> Juan: IN THIS COUNTRY FOR
SURE ARE YOU KIDDING?
THAT'S WHY YOU ARE ASKING
THE QUESTIONS.
>> Jesse: WHY DO YOU THINK
THAT IS.
>> Juan: REPUBLICANS WITH
THIS PRESIDENT HAVE A
DIFFICULT HISTORY AND
DIFFERENT PATH WHEN IT COMES
TO RACE.
>> Jedediah: THAT'S NOT
FAIR, JUAN.
>> Jesse: REPUBLICAN PARTY
IS THE ONE THAT FREED THE
SLAVES.
>> Jesse: REPUBLICAN IN
ALABAMA IS STILL IN OFFICE.
>> Jesse: I DISAGREE IT
MATTERS IF IT'S REPUBLICAN
OR DEMOCRAT IT'S BAD NO
MATTER WHICH PARTY DOES IT.
DANA?
>> Dana: THE ELECTION IS
ALREADY VERY CLOSE.
ASIDE FROM THIS INCIDENT
THERE IS A BIG ETHICS
SITUATION THAT'S BEEN
DOGGING THE TRUDEAU
INVESTIGATION FROM THE
BEGINNING.
SO FAR THE FRENCH MEDIA HAS
STAYED VERY MUCH IN HIS
CORNER.
THAT'S WHERE HIS POLITICAL
FOUNDATION IS UP IN THE
QUEBEC AREA.
REMEMBER, HE WAS KIND OF
CANADA'S PRESIDENT OBAMA.
HE WAS HOPE AND CHANGE.
AND HE WAS THE POLITICAL
DYNASTY OF THE TRUDEAUS.
THE ENGLISH MEDIA, HOWEVER,
IS REALLY GOING AFTER HIM
VERY HARD.
BUT, IF YOU THINK OF RALPH
NORM, VIRGINIA, THE PEOPLE
THERE HAVE PRETTY SHORT
MEMORIES.
IF YOU CAN ALL RIGHT STORM
NORMENT IS LIKE I'M NOT
REALLY SURE IF THAT'S ME.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW.
TRUDEAU HAS A DIFFERENT
TACTIC I'M GOING TO GO ALL
IN AND APOLOGIZE AND HOPE HE
CAN GET THROUGH IT.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS IN 18984
RALPH NORTHAM AND THIS IS IN
2001.
THE SITUATION IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENTIAL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HAVE YOU
TRUDEAU AND SOME OF THESE
HIGHLAND
HOGHLAND
HOLLLAND
HOLLYWND
HOLLYWOOD CELEBRITIES.
ACTORS IN BLACK FACE ALWAYS
THE MOST VOCAL PEOPLE WHEN
ACCUSING OTHER PEOPLE OF
BEING RACIST.
CAN YOU ACCUSE SOMEONE OF
BEING A RACIST IF YOU WEAR
BLACK FACE?
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN.
>> Mike: IT WAS AMAZING TO
WATCH THE MEDIA CONGRESS FEW
AND THEN I MIGHT HAVE DONE
DAO.
SERIOUSLY YOU DID THE BANANA
SONG?
CRAZY.
HE WASN'T EVEN DONE
APOLOGIZING AND DON LEMON ON
CNN ISN'T THAT NICE HE?
APOLOGIZED.
TRUMP WOULD NEVER APOLOGIZE.
IT WAS INSANE.
TRUMP COULD COME OUT OF A
BURNING BUILDING CARRYING
ORPHANS THEY WOULD BE LIKE
WHY DID YOU START THE FIRE
AND WHAT'S WITH THE BLACK ON
THE FACE, DONALD.
THE TRUDEAU THING, THERE IS
MORE COMING.
I GUARANTEE THERE IS MORE
COMING.
>> Dana: HOW MANY TIMES DO
YOU DRESS UP AS AN ADULT.
>> EXACTLY.
BUDDY DRESSES UP LIKE A
WOMAN HALLOWEEN AND DOES IT
NEXT HALLOWEEN.
>> Jesse: THERE IS A THING
THERE.
>> HE THINKS OF HIMSELF AS
CANADA'S BARACK OBAMA.
HE IS ACTUALLY CANADA'S BETO
O'ROURKE.
HE SOUNDS COMPLETELY PHONY
AND/OR COMMITTEES
STRAIGHTED.
I DON'T BELIEVE ANYTHING HE
TALKS ABOUT THIS NEED FOR
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION.
I DON'T BELIEVE HIM WHEN HE
SPEAKS HIS PAST AND WHAT YOU
ARE SEEING AS A REALITY
WHAT'S GOING ON IN HIS LIFE
AS A GROWN ADULT MAN
REFLECTS THAT BETO DOES THE
SAME THING HERE.
HE GETS UP ON THESE PODIUMS
AND SAYS ALL THIS STUFF.
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU ARE
SITTING AT HOME AND SOMEBODY
ELSE WROTE IT AND HE IS
DELIVERING IT AND NOT
AUTHENTIC.
THAT'S HOW I HAVE ALWAYS
FELT ABOUT THIS GUY AND HIS
PAST IS PROVING IT TRUE.
>> Juan: I'M ASSUMING IS HE
SPEAK FROM THE HEART.
I'M NOT GOING TO CALL THE
GUY HYPOCRITE.
HE SAYS UNCONSCIOUS RACISM
SORT OF IMPLICIT CASUAL
RACISM.
HE JUST THOUGHT -- HE DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND HOW PRIVILEGED HE
WAS AND HOW OTHER PEOPLE
MIGHT INTERPRET THIS.
>> Jedediah: 29?
>> Jesse: JUAN, BE SERIOUS
FOR A SECOND.
IT'S 2001.
>> Juan: RIGHT.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN HAVE SO
MUCH PRIVILEGE.
YOU CAN HAVE PRIVILEGE
COMING OUT OF YOUR EYEBALLS
AND STILL KNOW THAT BLACK
FACE IN 2001 NOT A GOOD
MOVE.
>> Juan: I AGREE.
>> Mike: SUBCONSCIOUSLY WORK
THROUGH THAT ISSUE ONLY BY
DRESSING IN BLACK FACE CAN
YOU UNDERSTAND THE RACISM.
>> Juan: IF YOU ARE INVITED
TO ARABIAN KNIGHT THEMED
PARTY WOULD YOU SAY I BETTER
BE CAREFUL?
>> Dana: I WOULD GO AS A
CAMEL.
>> Jedediah: COUPLE HUMPS
CLEAN.
OR YOU WEAR THE ROBE, JUAN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WATER
BLACK FACE.
>> Jedediah: DID HE THIS
TWICE BEFORE AND IT OCCURRED
TO HIM LET ME DO IT AGAIN.
>> Dana: REMEMBER WHEN HE
WAS PRIME MINISTER AND HE
WENT TO INDIA AND HIS WHOLE
FAMILY DRESSED UP IN INDIA